Progressive uh Union organizer Brandon
Johnson let's go Brandon has been
elected mayor of Chicago Illinois well
certainly now the police will be
defunded right no in fact Brandon
Johnson has outlined a very sensible
plan for reforming and continuing to
improve policing in Chicago HuffPost
reports Brandon Johnson Progressive
Union organizer elected mayor of Chicago
Johnson's victory over Centrist Paul
vallis is a major achievement for the
activist left that is absolutely the
case Johnson is described in this
article as a black leftist and former
school teacher
Paul vallis was the former CEO of
Chicago Public Schools this Victory is
being called again by HuffPost one of
the starkest ideological proxy battles
in the annals of recent Municipal
politics and it is a historic
achievement for the activists left
likely to have Ripple effects across the
country okay that's the characterization
by HuffPost there's a lot there it may
be the case it may not be
um this is super interesting for a
number of different reasons first of all
remember that the former mayor of
Chicago Lori Lightfoot lost her primary
that's interesting in and of itself
sometimes when you see folks positioned
like Lori Lightfoot lose primaries it's
because there's a Resurgence by the
right meaning that you're going to see
some hardcore conservative or whatever
the case may be Chicago is not a
conservative City so it's not
particularly likely but sometimes when
you see incumbents defeated it's because
of a big shift this is a shift but it is
a shift to the left and it's another
reminder that a lot of these Republicans
in different parts of the country I know
Chicago is its own thing
but it's a warning if you combine this
with the results from Wisconsin
two right Wingers that they need to run
and meet voters where they actually are
not whether they not where they might
wrongly imagine voters to be and it is a
reality in the United States that on
issues on just about every issue most
parts of the country have moved to the
left now that obviously depends on where
you started more conservative areas have
moved to the left but they're still
conservative just less so and more
Progressive areas have moved to the left
and they're becoming more Progressive
the abortion results in Kansas are a
reminder of that so it's going to be
interesting to follow this it's also an
incredible path for Brandon Johnson to
this eventual Victory when he started
before the first round of voting in
Chicago he was polling two percent and
now he got himself to winning the runoff
and now becoming the mayor of Chicago so
he will be judged by the results this is
a victory ideologically for the
progressive left now he actually has to
come in and make things happen of course
Republicans around the country often
love to point to Chicago as the example
of just devastating anti-police uh
politicking and what happens when you
hamper police and crime explodes and gun
violence and all these different things
of course we know how to zoom out
and to take a more fact-based view when
it comes to gun violence in Chicago
despite Chicago's strict gun laws you
drive 40 minutes to Indiana or I think
it's like 60 or 70 minutes to Wisconsin
and all of a sudden it's much easier to
get firearms and you have to account for
that when it comes to oh they want to
defund the police defund the police
almost no one wants to defund the police
sure you can find some activists on the
left that say defund almost everyone
says reform and indeed Brandon Johnson
plans to reform the police and in some
cases from what I've seen him say it
might require actually adding funding in
order to achieve things through new
programs that they want to start so
we're going to watch and see but a big
night for the left a win in Wisconsin a
win in Chicago and yes we also saw the
failed former president Donald Trump
arrested we will talk about that after
the break now that we've gotten to some
of this very very good news